[music]
[dramatic music]
Critic: Wait a minute!
Where's the crawl? And the Star Wars title, and the big music?
Well, it's a different kind of Star Wars movie.
D'ahh!
You see, this isn't part of the trilogies that spanned three generations.
This is more of a spinoff film.
It's a story that stands on its own, but also happens to be in the same universe.
Hence the title. Rogue One: A Star Wars Story.
Ok, Chris, why the hell are you talking like that?
Like what?
Like I'm somehow in front of you even though I'm clearly to your left.
That's just the Chris Stuckman tradition.
I always address the camera with my edited thoughts.
It's kind of... the Chris Stuckmann way!
Yeah, well, how about the Star Wars way, and we have an opening crawl?
I told you, Critic, it's not that kind of movie.
Rogue One is the first of what is currently an unending series of Star Wars Universe films.
While the trilogies will continue to follow the stories of the characters we know and love from the first movie,
these will be more background stories.
Think of them as the appendix in The Lord of the Rings.
A way to get more history of fictional events and characters.
They're standalone films that give us more information on a world we can't get enough of.
So the idea of cutting out the crawl is just a way to show it's one of the many side stories that's yet to come.
But we had another holiday theme! A Star Wars Solstice.
This is totally gonna ruin next year when we do
a Star Wars Feast Day Of Our Lady Of Guadalupe.
Look, this is just what Star Wars is now.
It can't be any worse than the changes they made in the past.
No, this is MY show, and I want a crawl!
Let 'er roll!
[mechanical elevator sounds]
[Star Wars-like music]
Now that's more like it!
WHOAAAAA!!!!
[thud, thud]
Hey! What's the holdup?
I'm sorry, we're only making letters float through space!
If you can think of a better way to make letters float through space,
then I'd like to see it!
GRRRHHHHHH!!!
Well, I guess we're stuck here for a bit.
Hey, look! I'm a kitty cat!
Knock that off!
While we're waiting for the crawl to get fixed, I guess we should go ahead and start the review.
You got it!
Stop that!
This is Rogue One.
[no audio]
Oh!
[dramatic music]
Sir, why did we park so far away?
Chris: So a young brunette girl with a British accent is separated from her family
as she spends most of her life with no direction, trying to cope with that tragic day.
Actually, that was Rey's character from Force Awakens.
Oh yeah, duh! How did I get those two mixed up?
[clears throat]
Chris: So a young brunette girl with a British accent is separated from her family
as she spends most of her life with no direction, trying to cope with that tragic day.
Not that Star Wars doesn't have a lot of repeat, but don't you think that's a little cut-and-paste?
Oh, I'm sorry. I guess the young American guys didn't get enough attention.
Critic: Ok.
Chris: Fair enough.
Critic: After cheerfully accompanying the Rebel Alliance,
Jyn is taken to their headquarters where one of Rebels named Cassian
reveals that her father Galen is the architect of a new weapon called the Death Star.
The man who raised you named Saw --
[snort] His name is Saw?
Trust me, you'll forget all these names once the movie is over.
-- has secret information from your father.
We're hoping you can infiltrate him to figure out what it is.
Well, I don't want to, but I guess I have no choice.
Critic: Now, how long did it take to say all that? Less than a minute?
Chris: I guess.
Critic: So, why does it take us less than a minute
and the movie a DOZEN minutes to say the same thing?!
This movie goes beyond taking its time.
It stretches out so much info for a story we already kind of have figured out.
It's like watching it in slo-mo yet they somehow talk in normal speech.
Chris: Some of it doesn't even add up,
like when this pilot named Rook
wants to defect for the Rebellion, yet Saw doesn't trust him,
so they hook him up to a lie detector squid.
Saw: This squid can sense your feelings,
your lies, and your inner thoughts.
Ok... how does he do that?
-- I don't know.
Where did you find him?
Why does he want to help you out?
-- I don't know.
What'll you do if I'm lying or not lying?
What DO you know?
-- I really like tentacle hentai.
Ughh, that's gross!
-- LIES!
Chris: It also doesn't help that this movie jumps all over the place.
It seems like every other minute, it cuts to a new planet or solar system.
I'm taking you to Rebel headquarters.
I'm taking you to find Saw.
I'm taking you to the Death Star.
I'm taking you out to lunch.
I completely forgot why we came here.
That's right, lunch!
It's like they're trying to make a simple story seem bigger by constantly trying to seem angry and busy.
Ah, the George Costanza method.
-- Basically.
Chris: Thankfully, their team is full of people who distract from that like K-2SO.
Critic: Who's kinda like C-3PO if they sucked out all the pussiness.
Greetings and salutations. I am C-3P--
Ohhhh, piss off, you pansy! Suck my big black rod!
Chris: There's also a freedom fighter named Baze
whose philosophy is shoot first, ask questions in... whatever this world calls hell.
Critic: Actually, I think it's just hell.
Chris: So this universe has both angels and hell, yet no Christianity?
Critic: Keep with the Midichlorian Church.
Critic: And then of course there's the blind warrior named...
Umm... yeah. I'm just calling him Toff.
Chris: But the downside is, while many of them are entertaining,
we don't really know that much about them.
We have no idea how these two know each other.
Why the pilot Rook defected.
Or why the hell Squidward was in this movie!
Critic: Dude, you gotta let that go.
Chris: NO! What... WAS that??
Why was that in the movie?! Stop putting scenes with tentacles your movies. They don't work!
Critic: It might be a good thing not knowing their stories though,
as when you do, it almost makes us less interested in them somehow.
-- I'm kind of angry with you.
-- I'm kind of angry with you too.
-- I thought you were my kind-of father.
-- I thought I kind of raised you.
-- I thought we had a kind of connection.
-- Kind of! -- Kind of! -- Kind of!
Saw: Wow, we went over everything, and I feel like, no attachment.
Yeah, I'm not gonna miss you when you die.
-- Speaking of which...
Whoa! Hoh... all right.
Chris: That blast, by the way, was a test by the Death Star
done by General Krennic and Grand Moff Tarkin.
Critic: Wait a minute. How did they do that if Peter Cushing is dead?
-- Oh, no, not!
-- That's right! Digital Talkin' Tarkin!
Available now from Hasbro for only $14.95!
Void where prohibited.
Oh, God! It's like Jeff Bridges from Tron Legacy mixed with Jim Carrey from A Christmas Carol.
Well, it's actually not THAT bad.
Sometimes.
The CG is very impressive. It always looks like somebody's really there.
But the uncanny valley distracts from ever fully accepting it.
Critic: Sometimes he looks convincing,
but the rest of the time, you'd swear they put the fake lips of John Lennon from Forrest Gump on there.
Make it so they have nothing left on that planet.
No possessions? No religion? It's easy if you try, dick.
Dismissed.
Critic: Ugh, good, at least the scene is over.
Oh, and don't forget, we have like five more meetings in the next 24 hours.
UGGGHHHHHH!!!!
That's the other thing. He's in this film... a LOT.
Chris: It kind of makes you wonder why they didn't just replace him with Darth Vader
who's only given less than 10 minutes in the movie.
He's one of the most famous villains who always wears a mask.
Why not use this guy as much as possible?
Critic: Well, to be fair, it might be because James Earl Jones's voice is sounding a little tired
after doing it all these years.
Vader: Oh my God, are they still making these?
Ok, where's the script. How many lines do I have?
What? That's it? Christ, I was in The Sandlot longer.
What am I, literally just taking a bath while I'm
off-screen?
Ok, ok. *clears throat*
Look here, General Krennic.
Krennic? What the hell kind of name is that?
It's like in one ear and out the other, forgotten.
I forgot I even said it.
Oh, fuck it. Just don't have me scream "noooo" and we'll be good.
Chris: I don't care if he sounds old. He's Darth Vader!
We deserve more of him.
Remember when this guy directed Aaron Taylor Johnson, also starring Godzilla?
Oh, that Godzilla movie that had almost no Godzilla!
-- Right!
Oh yeah, but to be fair, that movie had such bland main characters
that just weren't that interesting and you couldn't get sucked into.
You see where I'm going with this?
-- Yeah.
Critic: While the side characters work well enough,
our main leads are mostly pretty flat.
It's almost like they were given direction to not be awful, but not be interesting either.
How do you know your father's not the enemy?!
I saw his message. He's on our side!
-- Is that so?
-- Yes!
[buzzer sound]
I mean...
[subdued] Yes. In a totally passable yet unexceptional way.
I am passionate about this... but not too passionate
in case we're all to die at the end.
Right, so the people don't get too depressed
we can still market this as a deep, yet enjoyable adventure.
Oh, did I mention we have toys?
[ding]
OK!
[buzzer]
I mean, uh... ok.
[Nostalgia Critic theme sting plays]
Jyn's father is killed by the Empire as, once again,
it doesn't seem as emotionally investing as it probably should be.
Jyn, I put a weakness in the Death Star so small
that they'll never notice it.
In fact, it's so small, that every time they build a new one,
it'll have the exact same weakness.
Really? They never catch on?
They use Jolly Ranchers for badges. They're not exactly the brightest stars in the solar system.
Ok, I'm dead now.
Nooooooooo!!!
[buzzer]
Oh, I mean... uh...
[fake] No... father... whatever.
Chris: Upon finding out that the Rebels don't want to sneak in to get the plans for the Death Star,
our team decides to go it alone and get it themselves.
[on radio] You on that ship, what's going on?
Uh, everything's under control, situation normal.
[on radio] What happened?
Uh, had a slight weapons malfunction but we're perfectly fine here.
We're all fine here, now, thank you... how are you?
[on radio] What's your ship name? It better sound poetic and look good on a poster.
Our name? Uhh...
Just think of something. Hurry!
Uhh...
Rogue One.
[on radio] Rogue One? That sounds like a so-so comic series that was never given time to bloom.
Well, it makes more sense than just coming up with it out of the blue.
[blaster sound]
Boring conversation anyway. We're gonna have company!
Chris: So Rogue One goes to the Empire's base steal the plans,
the Rebels eventually end up joining them and...
Critic: You know how Force Awakens was friggin' awesome
but the climax was kind of... meh?
Chris: Rogue One was kind of meh, but the climax was friggin' awesome!
Critic: If you wanna know the truth, we haven't gotten a great space battle
since Return of the Jedi.
We did eventually get a good Star Wars film,
but the space battles were still usually too busy with too much clutter going on.
Chris: This follows one ship at a time again, making it feel like you're there.
In fact, a lot of it really feels like you're in the action because of the exciting,
even realistic way it's shot.
Critic: But it doesn't just stop there. It moves it to the next level.
Chris: You know how, in Return of the Jedi, they smash a Star Destroyer,
which, by the way, never destroys any stars.
Ironic because they have a weapon that destroys planets.
In fact, doesn't Death Star and Star Destroyer kind mean the same thi--
Critic: Ahem!
Chris: Anyway...
You remember how it smashed into the Death Star in a giant blaze.
Well, in this one, a ship pushes it in just the right place,
crashes into another Star Destroyer, which crashes into the shield blocking the planet,
and just before another one shows up, crashing into a dozen other ships!
It's AMAZING!!!!
This does still raise the question, though...
If Vader is in this movie, why isn't he down there on that beach kicking ass?
Stormtrooper: Uh, hello... sand?
Krennic: Oh, right. He hates sand.
Stormtrooper: It's so coarse and rough and irritating.
Krennic: And it gets everywhere.
Stormtrooper: He has posters, like, all over the place. How could you miss this?
Krennic: Ugh, I guess I'll have to go down there.
Stormtrooper: Don't you have like a million Stormtroopers?
Krennic: Yeah, but I can actually hit something!
Stormtrooper: What an asshole.
Chris: However, Darth Vader comes back.
Critic: By God, does he come back!
Chris: Just when you think he contributed nothing to this movie...
Critic: He comes aboard one of the ships and is like...
Vader: I have come to deliver the most awesome scene in the movie.
[lightsaber sound]
[dramatic music]
Vader: Yeah, no. This is nothing. This is literally nothing.
I can do this with no hands. Watch.
Ahh, yeah, mmm, get down, uhh, wah, yeah.
My saber is also great at making people shorter.
And you. You you you you! You belong on the ceiling!
Check it out, check it out. I'm not even looking at you. I'm not even LOOKING at you!
That's how easy this is! I'm so COOL!
Huh, look at his punk ass. Looks like Rebel Kool-Aid.
Ohh, that's right, bitches. I'm stopping that with my hand. With my goddamn hand!
But you know what they say,
what goes in, must come out. Out my ass. OK, here we go, everybody.
I am fucking amazing.
Ohh, whatchu gonna do, whatchu gonna do? Shit's getting hot in here, huh?
Oh, ok, yeah, we're gonna duke it out.
We're gonna duke it out!
You're a tough guy, huh? Oh, I'm so scared!
Darth Vader's gonna die from your pussy fists!
You're gonna save the galaxy with those hands, right?
Oh wait, I forgot, I can choke a bitch.
Dark Side, motherfuckers.
Both: Ahhhhhh...
Critic: So umm... yeah, that was the greatest Darth Vader scene in all movie history.
Chris: Despite all the film's flaws, it gave us two solid minutes of holy-shitness.
Critic: And speaking of flaws, there are still a few before we wrap up,
like how the emotional highlight is supposed to be the death of our two leads
you're not really gonna lose sleep over.
Jyn: You won't miss us.
Cassian: But you didn't dislike us either.
Jyn: Our job is complete.
[ding]
Chris: And because the Tarkin wasn't freaky enough,
we also get a CGI Princess Leia to top it all off.
Critic: Oh, Christ, just tell me they do it better than Tarkin.
Chris: Sometimes it looks better, and sometimes it looks worse. It's kinda weird.
Critic: How long is she on screen?
Chris: About ten seconds.
Critic: How can there be such a drastic change in only ten seconds?
Both: Ehh, it's not bad... pretty good... it's actually not bad...
Chris: FUCK! NO! SHIT DAMMIT!
Critic: No no no no no no no...
Both: Uhh, that's pretty good, better than the... everything and the...
Chris: Ohh FUUUUUUCK!
Critic: No no no no no no no!
Leia: We have a new hope.
Critic: You need an exorcist.
Thus the Rebels head off with the plans, and the film comes to a close.
And we were in this tooooo... !
Critic: And that was Rogue One.
Chris: The most above average Star Wars prequel.
Chris: The film has famously gone through rewrites and reshoots, and it clearly shows.
A lot of the time it feels all over the place, but some of the places they go to
have some great atmosphere and action.
The biggest problem is the characters aren't as memorable or fun as some of the other films,
meaning it doesn't feel as large or epic.
There's certainly problems with it, but it's hard to say there aren't a lot of cool scenes that overshadow them.
Critic: It's not fun, per se, but it is... cool.
It's definitely more aggressive and like an actual war, and that oftentimes make the world feel more real.
It never quite goes too aggressive, but it doesn't really take any chances either.
There's no surprises, and you get exactly what you expect,
but what I expected wasn't that bad, so I enjoyed myself fine.
It's a perfectly OK movie.
[mechanical elevator noise]
Chris: Oh good, they got the crawl working!
Critic: Oh, it's about time.
[Star Wars-like music plays]
You know, this does raise a good question.
What if we do get too many Star Wars movies?
Critic: I mean, before, Star Wars was gigantic, whether it was loved or hated.
But, what if it just becomes OK?
What if it's not great, not awful, it's just... average?
What if it becomes like every other franchise?
Chris: You know, before the prequels, there were a lot of cool Star Wars stories.
Books, video games, comics, and a lot of them had a wide variety of acceptance.
Some were great, some were awful, but some were just... OK.
So you see, Critic, Star Wars was a franchise before it was a franchise.
Critic: Huh, I never thought of it like that.
And yeah, we'll always have the original movies... ish.
I guess that does count for something.
Chris: You know, Critic, no matter what, Star Wars will always be special.
Critic: But will we ever get a Darth Vader scene as cool as the one in this movie?
Chris: Look, Darth Vader is one of the best villains of all time. They could do anything with him.
Who knows what's on the horizon that is Star Wars?
Critic: Like what?
Chris: OK, I felt like we were at a good spot there. It was a good spot to stop.
Critic: Really? I wasn't feeling that.
Chris: Oh, you weren't feeling that.
Critic: Like, like what?
Chris: Uhh... they could CG a cartoon face on Bea Arthur.
Critic: Wow, that'd be amazing!
Chris: Yeah, ok, we'll stop there.
Critic: More.
Chris: Ok, I really need an out. I need an out.
Vader: Yeah, I can fly too, bitches. I'm AMAZING!!!
I'm Chris Stuckman, and I can breathe in space for some reason.
Dude, that's it. We're done.
Nothing more. That's the last review of the year.
I don't know what else you're expecting. That's it. We're done. I'll see you in January.
Wait a minute. Next month is January.
You know what that means!
Sequel Month!
THE SEQUEL!!!
AAAAHHHHHH!!!!!
Vader: Dark Side, motherfuckers.
Subtitles by Jon Nelson (ylwsub68)
Hey, Doug Walker here doing the charity shoutout.
This week we are doing Action Against Hunger.
This is a international relief and development organization committed to
saving the lives of malnourished children and families
while providing sustainable access to safe water and long term solutions to hunger.
Recognized as a world leader in the fight against hunger,
they have pursued its vision of a world without hunger for nearly three decades,
combating hunger in emergency situations of conflict, natural disaster, and chronic food insecurity.
As part of the Action Against Hunger International Network,
with headquarters in New York, London, Madrid, Montreal, and Paris,
their field staff work in over 40 countries to carry out innovative, life-saving programs
in nutrition, food security, water and sanitation, health, and advocacy.
Their programs reach over 4 million people a year.
Both their site and their YouTube channel show all the people that they're helping, and how you can help them as well.
Nobody deserves to go to bed hungry, and you can help a child, an adult, anyone sleep well for several nights.
So please, click on the link, hear these stories, watch their videos,
and find out how you can make a huge difference.